high school football coach Joe Kennedy
lost his job in 2015 after he defied in
order to stop praying at the 50-yard
line after games the ninth circuit just
declined to hear one of his appeals not
surprisingly given it's the ninth
circuit but he says he is planning to
take that case all the way to the
Supreme Court coach Kennedy joins us
along with his lawyer Mike Barry of
first Liberty I see both coach first to
you were you surprised that the Ninth
Circuit refused to hear this and where
does that leave you exactly I wasn't
really surprised I only go by what I
hear from everybody else with the ninth
you know that it's I it was a long shot
to begin with but where does it leave me
is hopefully the Supreme Court you know
that somebody who actually hear the case
said I have a fair shot with so Mike
what's at stake here I mean it's not
just about one football game or one
coach there's maybe something bigger
yeah that's exactly right Tucker this
this is an outrageous decision that
really sets a dangerous precedent for
not just coach but school employees
across the country this decision if it's
not challenged means that if you're a
Jewish employee you can be fired for
wearing a yarmulke if you're a Muslim
employee you can be fired for wearing a
head covering if you're Catholic and you
wear a cross necklace you can be fired
and you know people have been asking
everybody from you know the President of
the United States to former NFL stars
have been pouring out support and folks
across the country want to know you know
what what can be done about this what
can we do we encourage people go to
first Liberty o RG to to support coach
and to get behind this petition to get
the Supreme Court to take this case yeah
and I hope I hope people will do that so
I'm coach Kennedy jog our memory here
who exactly was offended by what you
were doing how did it get to this place
yeah it originally started from a
compliment one of the educators saw what
we were doing out on the field and paid
the school district a compliment said
that what we were doing was awesome it
was good you know sportsmanship so it
all came from a compliment huh so but at
long the way somebody must have been
offended by it or you wouldn't have lost
your job
right only person that I I realized that
was really offended was the district
lawyers at that time and
they're the ones that are continue to
you know fight against me on this yes
there's no actual victim here just like
the most perverse part gentlemen thank
you for coming on and good luck I hope
you make it all the way to Supreme Court
hey thank you so much thank you Thanks